Why do come to us the humans are
returning they're hunting us you do
not know the sea we will learn your ways
if you want to live here I have to ride
we must protect the people
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my avatar of the way of water movie review
it's been 13 years since the first movie but you
know never to bet against James Cameron if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos but it has been 13 years
since the first movie came out I mean post all
the memes it's been so long James Cameron said
one of the reasons why it took so long is because
they assembled a writer's room to write all four
of the sequels because there's five movies total
in the franchise and then when he actually did
start filming the movie they started filming the
second two movies Avatar 2 and Avatar 3 back to
back so they film three at the same time Medina
will come out way sooner but on top of all that
he had to invent a lot of the technology that he
used in actually filming the movie it was kind of
the same deal when the first movie came out you
may remember they were hyping Up 3D technology
using the movie because he used these special
brand new cameras at the time and because he
did things that way it cost so much money to
make but all the money wound up on screen like
visually the movie looks amazing talking about
Avatar the way of water it'd been so long since
I've seen the first movie it reminded me of my
experience when I saw the first one because 3D
was a big deal back then even though the story
of the movie is meant to be very basic South
Park did a parody soon after called dances
with Smurfs because the plot is very similar
to the plot of Dances with Wolves but just on a
visual level the spectacle was amazing so it was
a great experience in the theater but the actual
writing of the second movie I felt like it was a
little bit better a little more Dynamic than
the first movie I mean it's still within the
tone of the first movie but overall the visual
spectacle of the film was amazing like it was a
great experience so if you do have the chance to
see the movie this weekend be sure to go see it
on the biggest screen possible I would recommend
IMAX if you can see it in 3D see it in 3D overall
the movie serves as a nice escalation of the first
movie A deepening of the lore because they raised
a lot of interesting ideas during the first film
that they start to get into during this film and
I suspect they'll spend the rest of the sequels
completely fleshing out they also do a pretty
decent job during the setting up the third movie
like obviously this is meant to be a big franchise
film he's kind of star warsing his movies where
you start with the characters and follow a family
across their timeline like you start with young
Anakin Skywalker and you end with Luke Skywalker
it'll probably be a similar path with the future
Avatar movies even though you've probably been
seeing all the funny posts of James Cameron
yelling about Marvel movies about Star Wars
movies like please do not compare my movies to
Star Wars to Marvel they're completely different
technology as a filmmaker but the audience doesn't
give a but in the real sense he's kind of building
his own franchise following some of the similar
beats that a lot of the Star Wars movies do
follow over time they're saying the movie costs
about 250 million dollars to make like I said all
the technology he created all the time he spent
building the world of the film visually the movie
looks completely different from the first film
obviously they travel to a water-based location
in the ocean this time with a water-based tribe to
make another Star Wars metaphor George Lucas said
that when he was designing his different trilogies
the original trilogy and then the prequels he said
when he moved on to the prequels and was doing
a completely different part of the timeline he
wanted it to look and feel very different which
is why the architecture the technology the plants
they go to seems so different and it's kind of the
same same Vibe with Avatar too like it looks very
different feels different from the first movie
while still carrying forward a lot of references
in Easter eggs to the first film like there are
a lot of returning characters but they introduce
a bunch of big twists so they feel like very
different versions of the characters the movie
does address the big time jump from the end of the
first film like Jake and neytiri have this large
family that's traveling with them now they've been
really busy in the time we haven't seen them but
in that same way James Cameron said that's his
plan for the future of the franchise too so like
Avatar 3 avatar 4 Avatar 5 will all feel and look
very different from this second movie if you're
a big fan of the avatar The Last Airbender
series there's actually a funny joke because
back in 2004 2005 when they were getting ready to
release avatar The Last Airbender animated series
they actually found out that James Cameron owned
the rights to the name Avatar because he'd been
planning on making that movie for a long time so
remember this is like years and years before the
first movie came out so Mike and Brian who were
making the Avatar The Last Airbender series had to
add The Last Airbender to the title otherwise it
would have just been called Avatar so the joke now
is that if James Cameron names Avatar 3 avatar the
fire bending Masters like goes to a new element
kind of like Avatar's different elements then we
Riot basic synopsis of the movie though is that
when it picks up Jake Sully, neytiri have formed
this family they're doing everything they can to
stay together like they mentioned the word family
almost more than Vin Diesel does in the Fast and
Furious movies however they must leave their home
explore the regions of Pandora when an ancient
threat resurfaces Jake must fight a difficult
war against the humans so they're like a couple
different things going on but the main villain of
the film is courage he's come back in an avatar
body the same way that Jake was able to survive
jumping to an avatar body at the end of that movie
within the world of the film it's meant to be
about 14 years since the end of the first movie
which is why some of their children are so much
older some of them are biological some of them are
adopted that's why they have the human child with
them even though they all have different roles
during the movie probably the most important one
everyone's going to be talking about is Sigourney
Weaver's character who's playing their daughter
Kiri her original character Grace Augustine died
during the events of the first movie and her
Consciousness was basically absorbed into the
Au creature this giant World Mine creature their
daughter Kiri has a special connection with AWA
that the other children don't have and she has
a special connection with the grace Augustine
character like they explain why she sounds exactly
like Sigourney Weaver in the first movie like I
said during this movie there's a deepening of
the lore of the mythology that will continue to
grow in future films as you can see during all the
trailer footage the Stephen Lang coach character
is a nice escalation version of the character like
the humans have escalated their tactics as the war
with the natives for the unobtanium becomes an
even bigger deal the way they actually treat the
story of this movie though is that it's meant
to feel kind of like a stand-alone Adventure
in the next movie when it picks up sounds like
it'll have at least a small time Jump and will
be like a completely different thing which is
why I made the Star Wars metaphor where each
of the different trilogies take place during
very different parts of the timeline like the
last couple of movies will take place much later
in the timeline when their children become adult
volts most of the major characters that survived
the events of the first movie are back in some
form Sam Worthington Zoe Saldana were great as
Jake and neytiri it does seem like the movie is
kind of transitioning them to more of a background
role just because their children seem like they're
going to become much bigger characters in the
future films I've already talked about Sigourney
Weaver coming back she actually jokes about what
James Cameron made her do kind of tricking her
into the role to begin with in a fun way like not
in a deceitful way but because she was playing
one of the children she actually joked that when
James Cameron makes movies he doesn't move in half
measures so he trained everybody in everything
that they needed to do during the movie even
though it's all motion capture you can hear Jim
under the water too so he directs you through
these sound systems in the tank and I wouldn't
come up it was easier for me to stay down there
because it was a long way up so I would just spend
hours down there so like Sigourney Weaver had to
learn to hold her breath for more than six minutes
underwater she had to learn a bunch of Parkour
like a bunch of the other younger characters it'd
be like bringing Mark Hamill back as a version
of young Luke Skywalker in motion capture but
then making him do like all this army training
need to get in super shape to do everything the
younger actors would do I've already talked about
Stephen Lang coming back as a version of Courage
he was great he's not meant to be the exact same
version of Courage like the whole idea is that his
Consciousness was transferred so he has all the
memories of the original courage but he's kind of
like this new version of the character all the new
actors playing their kids did a great job I feel
like they'll get bigger roles than future sequels
a lot of James Cameron regular actors came back
that you see in his other movies like Kate Winslet
plays a character during this Cliff Curtis also
plays the chief of the water tribe he was great
the music the score was great so even though we've
been making a bunch of jokes about this movie
trying to be relevant 13 years later like how
much do we care about the first movie just like
everybody trying to clown on the franchise the
whole joke is really that you never bet against
James Cameron and I feel like this movie will hold
true even though like James Cameron himself said
the movie will probably not turn a profit because
it costs so much money to make I think he said it
had to earn like a billion dollars in order to
turn a big profit I do not think that it's going
to earn as much money as the first movie did just
because of everything that's been going on in the
world and the box office Behavior the past couple
of years is just generally a bad time for movies
in general like a lot of people just have not
gone back to theaters yet but overall the movie
is pretty solid I only wish the last Terminator
movie had been this solid but to be fair like
you can't blame that on James Cameron because
he only helped a little bit like he was very
Loosely involved with the making of that movie
the vast majority of his time and energy the
past 13 years have been spent crafting the Avatar
franchise and that's why I say it all feels like
it wound up on screen like all the money all
the time the energy it all wound up showing on
screen so that's why it felt like such a great
experience even if the story was still pretty
simple by comparison to something like everything
everywhere all at once Avatar 2 isn't meant to be
like a Multiverse movie or anything like that I
just make the comparison Because the actual plot
of everything everywhere all at once was way
way more complicated to follow than something
like the Avatar franchise that being said it
was amazing like it was an amazing version of
what Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness should
have been ever even want to post your reactions
to the movie in the comments below please don't
post spoilers on this video I'll post a longer
breakdown video with Easter eggs everything for
the movie later this week after it actually comes
out and because they filmed Avatar 3 back to back
with Avatar 2 big reminder they plan on releasing
it in December 2024 so we wanted to wait that
long for it to come out but it's meant to feel
a completely different look completely different
completely different environment from what happens
in Avatar 2. I just did a huge video for the
Spider-Man across the spider-verse trailer you
can click here to watch that and click here for
my video on the Game of Thrones Jon Snow sequel
series thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!